may have slowed commercial air travel
but a lot more people apparently are
getting on board now
with traveling on a private jet
companies are seeing a rising demand
from people who are worried about
exposure
or cramped terminals in the age of kobit
but let's be real a private jet is
pretty costly kirsten joyce now joining
us with more a reasonable
alternative denise with 81 percent of
north american travelers planning to fly
domestically in the next six months
and folks reunited with family and loved
ones many for the first time this year
travelers are seeking less crowded and
safer travel alternatives such as
jsx the burbank las vegas market to this
day is our strongest market
alex wilcox is the ceo of jsx airlines
stands for joyful simple experience
a semi-private jet offered to the public
minus the expensive price tag you can
fly for 89
one way our biggest airplanes have 30
seats on them they're built for 50 seats
but we took some
some seats out to make some more room
it's all about convenience and time
saved other you know airport terminals
will tell you show up at least two hours
before your flight
we say please don't poke until 20
minutes before your flight
you do you're wasting a lot of time the
airline started five years ago with a
concord to burbank route followed by its
most popular one bourbon to las vegas
as many as 14 flights a day in each
direction here we are
more or less on the hour doubling its
number of flights every year until of
course the pandemic hit
but now that more people are starting to
feel comfortable to travel again
jsx's business since april has steadily
picked up
and continues to do so in travel hubs
like las vegas reno and arizona
even adding a route from vegas to dallas
due to strong demand
i can tell you that 65 of the business
is las vegas too
so it's a huge part of our comeback
story the airline has ramped up cleaning
and rolled out new sterilization
and contactless protocols we were social
distancing before it was even cool
kirsten
there was lots of space in the lounge
you know on a per customer basis we
didn't have the
same old security line uh you're not
taking your shoes off you know for
anybody no one's going to go through
toilet kits so
the likelihood of transmitting you know
anything uh even the common cold is
actually lower
uh the fewer people you're exposed to i
asked alex how he's able to make the
flight so affordable he says it's part
of their efficiency model they don't
have constraints at terminals don't have
to wait for hundreds of people to board
if it costs 5 000 a flight for an hour
and you divide that by 30 people
that's how you can get the reasonable
amount to charge